doesn't how is this food it doesn't look
edible this does not look like food
would you eat that
what's up guys today we are doing
Mexican wife tries Chinese snacks we
started this series a while ago where we
were trying each other's like cultures
candy yeah I tried some Mexican candy we
tried some Chinese candy this time it's
we're throwing it back towards the
Chinese way yep so we're doing Chinese
snacks today and if you haven't noticed
I'm talking a little quieter than normal
because Luke is actually sleeping right
now until maybe my seven month old baby
are you ready for some Chinese snacks
well I have a lot to show you and this
is like all the ones that I could
remember like oh yeah I hate those when
I was a kid the original cookie roll
that looks delicious I think I've had
this before you probably yeah you're
hanging out with my parents I'm sure
they've like snuck some of these towards
your way yeah maybe with their parents
but no I feel like I've tried them
growing up oh yeah another one is almond
cookies I definitely had those growing
up my mom used to always buy the Twin
Dragon almond cookies oh yeah that's
like basically this stuff yeah so these
are the ones that I grew up on like my
mom bought them all the time we always
had them so you basically you're telling
me the snacks I grew up on the Chinese
snacks I grew up on you had this you had
this but did you have this oh come on
bro really vanilla wasted like they're
the most common thing ever so these are
Chinese though they're like I don't know
I feel like they're all right what's the
difference I feel like they're less
sweet what about this one yeah okay
they're like rice treats I was gonna say
it looks like rice yeah like rice it's
like Chinese Rice Krispies treats
there's another one
spring onion crackers oh that's awesome
this is more of a Savory thing yeah not
a sweet one more gnarly stuff but yeah
Chinese jerky
yeah we got uh dried squid I've tried
that you've had this yeah with your
family when this bag opens especially if
you're on a car in a car for some reason
my parents love eating these only on
road trips it takes the car over and
then last but not least this is dried
pork floss is what they actually call it
yeah I don't know why well kids look at
it it's like oh yeah it's like the meat
completely dried up it looks like fur
doesn't it it looks like rope
yes it looked like rope when I was a kid
I used to be like hey Dad can we eat
some hair yeah
but before we dive into those snacks a
huge shout out to Magic experience for
sponsoring today's video now as someone
that grew up in the 90s it wouldn't be a
proper childhood if you didn't sit in
front of a TV watching Saturday morning
cartoons eating cereal now as an adult
you realize how much sugar was actually
in that cereal and now as a parent I'm
also very mindful about what my kids eat
for breakfast enter magic spoon magic
spoon is cereal reinvented it's Saturday
morning cartoon inspired but upgraded
for the 21st century consumer magic
spoon cereals have zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of proteins if you're
looking to get some extra protein hey
and only four to five net grams of carbs
in each serving plus each serving is
only 140 calories the keto friendly
gluten-free brain free soy free and low
carb ball tasting
like the cereal you remember eating as a
kid they come in variety packs with four
flavors to choose from frosted fruity
peanut butter cocoa personally I'm
loving the peanut butter one I'm a
sucker for anything peanut butter click
the link below and grab a variety pack
and try it out today here's the promo
code Tiff case at checkout to get five
dollars off any order or go to
magicspoon.com Tiff case and Magic
smooth is so confident in the product
it's backed with 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked alright so grab yourself a bowl of
cereal back through Chinese snacks all
right let's get some uh cookie rolls in
fresh egg roll
oh my gosh oh my gosh it takes me back
to my childhood one of the things about
any snacks is they're very flaky like
Chinese people love flaky things one for
each of us sounds like a cigar
ette
why did you inhale you're not supposed
to inhale when you smoke a cigar by the
way okay ready to Cheers
hmm
hmm good morning little Mom good morning
eating this in the flakiness
it reminded me of me and my friends
growing up we would eat this and then
for some reason we were obsessed with
you know like the the gag the slapstick
gag when like people are eating food and
they go okay
that's so cute yeah I could appreciate
you guys doing that because I know what
you look like when you're little that's
so cute there's like two idiot kids in
the corner so what would you guys like
think of that it's so funny if you're a
kid and you go like this and go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
I haven't had these this is like a
muscle bun yeah I was gonna say it's
like muscle pan but instead of peanut
it's almond
mmm that is really good it's not as
sweet as uh and that is buttery I can
actually eat the whole thing no you can
do that you can do it with this one oh
my God it keeps smacking yourself so
hard this is good I like this I don't
think I'm good with one I could eat more
of the other ones two powdery this one I
really want some of our drinks yeah
be careful these snacks are really
dangerous for backwash
they're so flaky yeah no water then
you're hanging out for me thank you
oh yeah I'm really thirsty we love
wafers me too what's your favorite
flavor strawberry cream do they have
strawberry no need help
yeah there we go oh it smells delicious
yeah I always remember my parents
getting a Chinese rabbit Wafers and
never the American kind these are fat
cheers
are they different to you they are right
that's what I thought too yeah they're
way more wafer it was like sweet there's
like zero filling it's very interesting
because
they would modify this to have less
sugar Asian people don't like sweet
compared to the general Western culture
I would say right if there could be a
wafer that's in between this and what's
already out there that would be perfect
because this is a little too too dry too
dry like too little filling the other
one's too much but it's still really
good because I'm used to it you're just
perfect for me it feels like nothing but
wafer for it being a vanilla wafer I'm
kind of let down but if it's like its
own thing not comparing it to anything
else it's really good I was recently on
Instagram and I thought some like video
posted how Asian people
judge desserts and they go not too sweet
it's good well I'm so Asian then because
I'm like oh yeah not too sweet that's so
good all right so true after being with
you for 10 years I agree all right next
one I'm actually the most excited about
this one oh this is sweet yeah I think
so oh yeah you could kind of see the
sugar on it
yeah
[Music]
that's not what my brain told me that it
smelled like it does look like a Rice
Krispie Treat though
I'll take the little one this brings
back childhood memories really why would
you eat these I don't remember
you know I really smell something you
know it brings back like yeah the
feeling of the genese yeah Nostalgia I
mean I don't have a specific like memory
though cheers
oh it's soft I thought it'd be hard
I think I liked it yet better when I was
a kid yeah I feel it stuck in my teeth
and I think we should have eaten this
first because it's so not sweet for a
sweet item that everything that we just
ate it's way more like I'm like there's
really no flavor yeah
I'm really surprised by the texture of
it though the way it just like falls
apart because it it's like it's held up
so well but then as soon as you just
touch it it like melts that's Chinese
Ingenuity no that's weird
what I don't know you invented fireworks
I mean I don't know and noodles
and soccer too I think so we're talking
about food though
I forgot I said fireworks so I had a
long-term memory lives yeah short-term
memory loss
this is what happens when you're
together for a decade you end up doing
the same dumb [ __ ] done with the sweets
moving on to some more Savory options
if I remember correctly this
if I remember correctly this is
addictive it's the Chinese Pringle I
would say once you pop pan you can't
stop I don't know just trying to help
you too like uh all right here we go
foreign
I could eat like 10 of those probably
wow
it's amazing how thin it is
oh you know what this tastes like I
never put two and two together as a kid
but as an adult I'm like this it's green
onion pancake
um
yeah these are not what I remember them
to be they're more saltier I guess yeah
they're kind of light I definitely want
to keep these in the house these need to
be a staple in our home it goes with
like Savory things I feel like you could
just pair this with some ham cheese like
a lunch you could replace the crackers
in a Lunchable with this exactly
beef jerky Chinese turkey should I get
the scissors they got a little thing
right here
is this what your parents were eating on
a road trip in Boston yeah pretty much
so every road trip my mom and my dad go
on yeah it smells really good you gotta
have this
and Skip ahead we gotta have this like
they always have to have their dried
Meats protected in particular like they
don't really care much for these types
of things
okay the meats oh they they go in on
this it's like softer than American
jerky you can just kind of pull it apart
oh yeah it's weird like American jerky
is like really hard and tough yeah
because they've like flatten it and
super dry it out yeah this doesn't feel
like it's as dry as the other yeah it's
like wetter
[Music]
seeing that rope look though
maybe like the ropeness I like it so
this is one of the more gnarly ones I
already hate the smell it is dry Squid
aka cuttlefish oh that's what cuttlefish
is I never knew yeah this is a picture
of a cuttlefish which is good right I
mean is that the same thing that's a
picture of a cuttlefish which I think is
squid yeah it's on the front too oh yeah
as I wear
oh my God it takes up the whole
packaging I bought a package of this
tell the story when I first found all
this stuff and actually bought all this
stuff like months ago thinking I was
gonna make this video but then we
started traveling and all this stuff so
I just never got around to making the
video but the point is at some point I
had to store this like I sat the whole
bag on the floor in the pan in the
pantry Pantry door is open one morning I
find this whole thing was completely
eaten up this whole bag of drinking the
plastic yeah the plat I'm like did you
eat the plastic too like there's little
plastic left over here and yeah I don't
know our cats tore that bag up
oh glorious road trip this is the smell
of road trips
[Music]
this is the smell of driving from Dallas
to Houston oh really this is the snow
I'm very grateful that your parents did
not bust this out during our recent Road
troops
and it smells crazy I think I tasted it
once because I'm down to always taste
anything more yeah it looks like a rope
too actually rope
snacks
flavored rope yeah it's not bad good huh
it's a little too much squid but
whatever it's coated in like sugar it's
like sweet yeah I did not expect it to
be sweet sweet and savory okay I've
never tried this before I did not expect
it to be addicting it's actually really
good it just smells really bad I'm not
bad but just too too fishy it's way too
much squid smell I think this is my
favorite snack so far I would still
stick to these pot pans
really cool actually
Chinese uh Lunchables right here pending
patent pending
oh very messy
[Music]
about these ones I'm not looking forward
to that pork hair
pork floss oh floss
how is this food it doesn't look edible
there's no smell there is but it's not
like it's super light because that was
so strong
the squid was so strong that that
doesn't seem like it has any flavor this
does not look like food would you eat
that all right last one this is like a
treat because I feel like this is one of
those like if you're not Chinese you
need a Chinese friend to introduce this
to you because I don't know Chinese
husband or Chinese husband yes because I
don't think you're gonna go out of your
way to find this appealing ever
[Music]
your reaction to this is hilarious
though oh man I really don't want to eat
this oh because I've I've literally
eaten someone else's hair a beard in
particular as a punishment
for one of the games and that was
gross and horrible and this is this is
triggering me cheers
okay so once it gets all wet and that
like
hair texture is gone it turns into like
beef jerky and the flavor's not bad
flavor is really good but I really don't
want to experience that again like the
thin hair things in my mouth I didn't
like it how is this even made I have no
idea that's the real question here oh my
God these cats are already lingering
around here they know what's up they
have good taste buds
all right thanks for watching guys if
you have tried any dope
[Music]
oh we got the kid
you know we're stirring
[Music]